-You look sharp, buddy.
Welcome back to our show.
Thank you for being here.
-It's so nice to be here
and not in my office
at home via Zoom.
-Yeah, Zooming, yeah.
-Yeah.
-We have a live audience.
-Actual live audience.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's the best.
You have a big weekend
coming up.
'Cause you just finished
a run of "Cabaret."
-That's right, yeah.
-In London.
I have a photo of you
in "Cabaret."
Look at you.
Congrats on this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That is me
under there somewhere.
-You were nominated for
an Olivier Award on Sunday.
-Yeah.
-That's fantastic.
-You know what, it's --
this is --
I played --
this looks
like a sort of bejeweled
haute couture Skellington.
But actually this is --
I play the Emcee in "Cabaret,"
and I played it as a kid
when I was at school.
So it's always been one
of those lifelong dreams,
and the whole show was a dream.
So I'm thrilled.
Yeah, it's the sort of cherry on
top of the --
Christmas cake?
-Yeah, cherry on top.
Yeah. Cherry on top, yeah.
"Cabaret" is, you know --
It's a little --
It's a little dark.
-It's pretty dark.
-Your kids probably didn't --
didn't see it, did they?
-Well, my kids are like
five and four.
And I took them to the theater
recently to see "Frozen,"
which they loved.
-"Frozen" is fantastic.
-It's fantastic.
And they're sort of beginning
to understand that I'm an actor.
And I say,
"Daddy's doing a play
and doing a musical tune.
Do you want to come
and see the theater?"
And they came.
They saw that scary costume,
and that terrified them.
And so I showed them the stage.
And I kind of, you know,
sang a little song for them.
And they're like, "That's great,
Dad, but it's not 'Let It Go.'"
-No, it's not "Let It Go."
It will never be "Let It Go."
-And more depressing is that,
like, the songs from "Cabaret"
are like --
the song that I was listening
on repeat learning it was like,
♪ Money makes the world
go around ♪
But it's like a really
dark sort of take on that.
And so my kids are like,
♪ Money makes the world
go round ♪
No, No, No --
-Let's put on "Frozen."
Let's put on "Frozen."
That's much better.
"Frozen 2," whatever you want.
-Exactly.
-Your first acting role --
is this correct?
Was it "Oliver"?
-Yeah.
Yes, gosh, you did
your research.
-I did a little research.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Who did you play in "Oliver"?
Were you Oliver?
-It's still actually
quite painful.
-Everyone has to start
somewhere.
-And the other thing in "Oliver"
is like,
you're either Oliver
or you're Dodger
or you're one of the gang.
There are hundreds
of children's parts.
But I had the famous part
of the book boy,
who is not in the gang,
isn't Oliver.
Has one line.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The book boy!
Oh, my God,
we love the book boy.
Oh, my God, yeah.
That's our favorite character.
-The favorite character.
I had one line.
And it went like this,
"Books you wanted
from the bookseller, sir."
I had to come on.
-Wow.
Nailed it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's how you do it.
-But it was a big deal for me
and it was
at the London Palladium,
which was like
a huge theater in London.
And the first night that I
went on, I delivered my line,
and I just walked very,
very slowly off,
took about three minutes.
Sort of royal wave --
the director was like,
"Mate, this isn't --
You're not Oliver.
You're not Dodger."
-No, you're gonna break --
-"Get the hell off the stage."
-People are gonna remember
the bookseller kid.
-Exactly.
-"Here's your book, sir."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Slowly walk out.
But when you were first
starting out,
you had some
pretty famous roommates.
-True.
-In L.A.
-It's been interesting.
So, about -- what was it --
15 years ago when --
there's this thing in England
in the winter.
It rains a lot.
And in L.A.,
it's really sunny, and there's
this thing called pilot season.
And so, all these kind
of out-of-work
English actors go over to L.A.
to try and get work,
which we tend not to get.
But what we would do is just,
like, be in the sunshine
and then sort of call home
and tell our families
that we were working
incredibly hard.
-[ Laughs ] I get it.
It's sunny out in L.A.
-It's sunny out in L.A.
But there was this group of us,
and some of us lived together,
some of us didn't.
And -- But we would always go
and hang out and play.
And none of us got jobs.
And then someone would get a job
and sort of go stratospheric
and then the rest of us
would sit back and --
-"What are we doing
with our life?"
-Yeah.
-Play Ping-Pong.
-There was a lot of Ping-Pong.
-These are people
like Andrew Garfield?
-Andrew, very good
at Ping-Pong.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Fierce, fierce Ping-Pong player,
Garfield.
-Is he really?
-Yeah, and I just remember
that he did once come --
you know when you play tennis
and someone comes with,
like, a bag
and maybe with two rackets.
-Yeah.
-I just remember once playing
with Andrew and he turned up
with a Ping-Pong bat
in a, like, case.
I was like,
he is not messing around.
But he's a very good
Ping-Pong player.
-How is Robert Pattinson?
-Rob, I didn't play
Ping-Pong with.
Jamie Dornan I played
-Jamie Dornan too?
I mean, this is
the house of studs.
I mean, what is going on?
-Well, it's funny because --
[ Cheers and applause ]
There was this thing
I read the other day
because Jamie and Rob have been
promoting things recently,
they were being asked
about this.
And I read something about like
how Jamie was sort of
bemoaning the fact
of how stressful
it was going to a club with Rob
because everyone
would look at Rob
and no one would look at him.
I was like, "Dude."
-You're Jamie --
-Try being me, man.
[ Laughter ]
Jamie, face of Calvin Klein,
billboards in New York,
sort of six-pack.
I was like, "Dude, let's not."
-Please, yeah.
Give me a break.
-Cry me a river.
-A river, yeah.
Also --
I read something
that Robert Pattinson was saying
because he was promoting
"The Batman."
And he was saying
he would go to auditions
and sometimes
you're in the audition
and there's someone in the room
ahead of you auditioning
and either get applause
or get a big reaction
and it makes you nervous
because you're like,
"I got to follow that?"
And the door would open,
and you would come out.
And he'd be like, "Oh, wow,
you killed it again, buddy.
Congrats."
-He's not doing
too badly, is he?
-No, he's not.
He's doing okay.
-The thing about Rob
and it was interesting,
'cause this whole bunch of us
and there was Charlie Cox,
Tommy Sturridge --
A load of us who all have
remained really good buddies.
But each of us had our own
kind of audition technique.
And Rob and Tom's was always
like whatever the scene
appears to be on the page,
you do the complete opposite.
And so, I would be
sitting outside,
and I thought it was
a quiet, intimate scene
and I just hear sort of shrieks
inside the room.
I was always -- We're basically
all desperately
trying to find
our way to like...
-Of course.
-...stand out from the crowd.
-He would just open
the door like,
"I'm not going to get that one."
[ Laughter ]
-But good shrieks.
-Yeah, good shrieks, he tried.
I want to talk about the new
film "Fantastic Beasts:
The Secrets of Dumbledore."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can I quickly just tell
one more story?
Because when we made
"Fantastic Beasts,"
it was at the same studio
that Rob was making "Batman."
-Oh, yeah.
-And we shared a gym
because my character
and my body is so buff.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, one day
I went to the gym,
and I walked in
and there was this guy
with, like, a high ponytail.
Massive, doing the most
extraordinary stunts
I've ever seen
with his stunt director.
And it was that slightly
embarrassing thing
when you're a skinny runt
and you go into a gym
and there's someone --
and this is, like, the same gym
that Jason Momoa goes to.
You're quite used to --
-I would walk the opposite way.
-And I walk in and this guy
goes, "hi" and I go "hi"
and then I just sort of
sit there watching him
do these incredible things
while I sort of weakly do
a sit-up in the corner.
-You're like waving a wand
in the corner.
[ Laughter ]
-Gotta get my wand on.
-[ Grunting ]
You're like, "I'm good."
-It was that.
It was that.
Anyway, after 40 minutes
of doing this,
I sort of --
not 40 minutes. 10 minutes.
I sort of scuttle off,
and as I'm going,
this guy goes, "Bye, Eddie."
And I look back, and it was Rob.
And he was so physically
changed and he had a man bun.
And what I had seen him
do was so dumbfounding.
It was -- He completely
transformed himself.
I felt very lucky to see him
because "Batman"
is so brilliant
and his work in it.
I felt really lucky
to see his commitment.
-Isn't that fun to see?
I like seeing my friends
at work.
-This was at 5:00
in the morning.
He's like sort of --
I was doing my wand lifting
and he was doing ferocious,
hard-core fights.
-He went for it. Yeah.
He did look different.
-It was very impressive.
-Speaking of impressive,
this is
another "Fantastic Beasts:
The Secrets of Dumbledore."
I love watching you in any role
that you play.
You always dive right in.
For this third installment,
it's a giant film.
It's a giant deal.
Is there anything you could
say about it or --
'cause I don't want
to give away secrets.
-What I love about this one
is it feels like
it's a sort
of wizarding heist movie.
It's kind of like "Oceans 11."
-But for young family.
-In a wizarding, like, world.
-Yes, I love that.
I love that. Yes.
-Is that a way to try and --
-Yeah, it's a perfect way
to sell it.
-And Jude Law,
who plays Dumbledore,
is basically George Clooney
and I'm Brad Pitt.
[ Laughter ]
-And that's -- So he's George,
you're Brad and that's --
-Can't you see the similarity?
-Yes, exactly right.
You know what?
I was going to ask you --
every time you're here --
I don't mean to bother you.
You don't have to do this.
But you always either
bring me something
from the set
that you've learned
or a magic trick
you showed me once
or something you had
to physically do in the movie.
Do you have
any embarrassing things?
-It's worse than that.
Because I feel that
on the first movie,
they made me do a mating dance
with basically a rhino.
[ Laughter ]
And then I came
and taught it to you.
-Oh, please.
-Which was wonderful to be able
to throw the humiliation
onto you.
And I feel like now
in each of these movies,
they literally write
something to humiliate me
and when I read it, I go,
"That's horrendous but great
because I get
to teach it to Jimmy."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What did you do this movie?
-So, in this movie,
there are these little critters
called manticores
and they kind of look like --
they look like
sweet little lobsters.
But they're actually terrifying.
And in order to kind of calm
these little manticores,
I have to sort of adopt
their movement.
[ Laughter ]
So would you --
Can I teach it to you?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We have to.
It's a tradition.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a tradition now
at this point, yeah.
-I feel like last time
we did this,
you split your pants.
[ Laughter ]
Or I did.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, I did.
Yeah, I did.
-So, we might need to prep.
-Okay.
-Prep your trousers.
-Yep, okay.
My trousers are pretty prepped.
-Okay.
-Alright.
-So you start with a...lunge.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do it again, do it again.
-Do it again?
Start tall, start tall.
They're not suspecting it
and then a...lunge.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is good.
And now -- Now,
once you're down here,
and this is why
I was in the gym
because you need those --
-It's all core right now.
-Those glutes and core.
So you then gently...move out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can you do that?
-Don't look.
Do it again.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-And now --
now you have to start
moving this way.
-Okay.
All right.
All right, all right.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Eddie Redmayne
in "Fantastic Beasts:
The Secrets of Dumbledore."
Take a look at this.
-Follow me.
Come on.
♪♪
You're not swiveling properly.
Swivel, swivel, but delicately.
-I'm swiveling
like your swiveling.
-I don't believe you are.
-Oh, how fun.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, how fun?
I can't wait for that.
Eddie Redmayne,
"Fantastic Beasts:
The Secrets of Dumbledore"
is in theaters and IMAX
April 15th.